François Mitterrand a connu Bernard-Henri
Lévy — « BHL » pour les intimes —
l’ancien président français a connu BHL
assez jeune.
Voici ce qu’il dit de lui dans son livre
L'Abeille et l'Architecte :
« J’ai connu Bernard-Henri Lévy alors
qu’il venait d’entrer à Normale supérieure.
Je me flatte d’avoir pressenti en ce jeune
homme grave le grand écrivain qu’il sera.
Un danger le guette : la mode. »
BHL est-il devenu un grand écrivain ?
Pour l’instant, il n’est pas considéré
comme tel.
En revanche, il est bien à la mode.
Les sondages réalisés dans les années 2010
montrent qu’il est l’intellectuel le plus
connu des Français.
Mais il est aussi controversé.
Son influence médiatico-politique et sa proximité
avec les puissants en font un symbole de la
dimension oligarchique des élites françaises.
Et effectivement, ce qui est étonnant dans
le destin de BHL, c’est la concentration
des pouvoirs.
Il aurait pu se contenter d’être riche.
Il aurait pu se contenter d’être influent.
Il aurait pu se contenter d’écrire des
best-sellers.
Mais il fera tout cela à la fois.
Comment est-ce que c’est possible ?
Je vais vous répondre à travers 10 anecdotes
vraiment étonnantes sur la vie de BHL.
Peut-être que vous ne l’aimez pas, mais
écoutez-moi jusqu’au bout — vous ne le
regretterez pas.
Après la campagne présidentielle de 2007
sort un nouveau livre de BHL, Ce grand cadavre
à la renverse, qui parle du déclin de la
gauche française
(dont BHL dit qu’elle est sa famille politique).
La métaphore du « grand cadavre à la renverse
» est de Sartre, un des modèles de BHL.
Dans ce livre, BHL accuse Jean-Pierre Chevènement,
qui est l’homme politique emblématique
du souverainisme de gauche en France
(c’est-à-dire une vision politique qui
ambitionne de limiter les écarts de richesse
grâce à l’indépendance du pays)
— BHL accuse Jean-Pierre Chevènement d’avoir
« saboté » la campagne de la candidate
socialiste à l’élection de 2007, Ségolène
Royal.
Réponse de Chevènement :
« La place que font les médias au sieur
Bernard-Henri Lévy, milliardaire déguisé
en philosophe, est révélatrice du profond
abaissement intellectuel, moral et même spirituel
de ce moment de notre Histoire ».
Milliardaire déguisé en philosophe…
Cette critique colle à la peau de BHL.
En 2011, il défend DSK — qui est son ami
— lors de l’affaire du Sofitel.
Cela provoque des réactions ulcérées de
la presse américaine.
Dans le concert de critiques, le ​​rédacteur
en chef du magazine Reason qualifie BHL de
« milliardaire narcissique à la chemise
déboutonnée ».
Même aux États-Unis, on lui reproche sa
fortune.
Mais milliardaire… vraiment ?
En francs, peut-être — et encore, selon
les estimations les plus hautes.
Elles varient entre plusieurs dizaines et
une centaine de millions d’euros.
BHL hérite de cette fortune en 1997,
lorsque l’entreprise d’importation de
bois de son père (disparu 2 ans plus tôt)
est revendue en quasi-intégralité à l’homme
d’affaires François Pinault
— qui est lui, pour le coup, un vrai milliardaire.
Si les critiques de BHL le qualifient de « milliardaire
», ce n’est donc pas parce qu’il a ce
niveau de richesse,
mais plutôt parce que son train de vie semble
incompatible avec un rapport philosophique
à l’existence.
C’est vrai que dans l’imaginaire occidental,
le philosophe trouve son épanouissement dans
la pensée — pas dans le luxe ;
le philosophe se contente de peu, comme Épicure
;
il met sa force morale à l’épreuve, comme
les stoïciens ;
voire il vit comme un ascète, en rejetant
les biens matériels, comme Diogène le cynique.
BHL, lui, a un train de vie… de millionnaire.
À Paris, il évolue essentiellement dans
le chic quartier de Saint-Germain-des-Prés,
qui est le cœur de la vie intellectuelle
parisienne.
Il a des domestiques et un chauffeur.
Il fréquente également les hôtels les plus
luxueux du monde entier
— il les considère comme son bureau d’écrivain.
Par ailleurs, si BHL n’est pas lui-même
milliardaire, il FRÉQUENTE les milliardaires.
Il est par exemple l’ami de François Pinault,
qui a racheté l’entreprise de son père,
et de Jean-Luc Lagardère, qui était à la
fin du XXe siècle un magnat des médias.
Si BHL n’a pas une fortune comparable aux
leurs, il est lui aussi un patron d’entreprises
: des sociétés de gestion de patrimoine,
d’investissement, de production de musique
ou de cinéma.
Et puis il a également une expérience du
monde de l’entreprise.
Du vivant de son père, il était en charge
de la communication interne de l’entreprise
familiale, avant d’en devenir le vice-président.
Nous sommes en mai 68.
BHL est en prépa littéraire à Louis-le-Grand.
Comme beaucoup d’étudiants, il adhère
aux idées révolutionnaires qui défèrlent
sur la société française.
Mais voilà : il ne peut pas participer aux
manifestations.
Il préfère réviser pour le concours de
l’École normale supérieure.
Alors que le concours approche, certains de
ses camarades le poussent à boycotter les
examens d’entrée par solidarité avec les
manifestants.
BHL refuse.
Il paraît qu’il était même un de ceux
qui ont fait pression sur les autorités de
l’école afin que le concours soit maintenu
malgré les « événements ».
Le concours a bien lieu, et BHL est admis.
Cette anecdote révèle qu’il a besoin de
la légitimité intellectuelle que confère
la prestigieuse école de la rue d’Ulm,
qui a formé certains des intellectuels français
les plus célèbres, comme Jean-Paul Sartre,
Raymond Aron, ou Michel Foucault.
Pour parler comme Bourdieu — normalien lui
aussi, et qui détestait BHL
— pour parler comme Bourdieu, BHL a, via
sa famille, le capital économique,
mais il n’a pas le capital culturel,
c’est-à-dire le savoir et les expériences
culturelles qui permettent à un individu
qui les maîtrise de manifester son appartenance
à l’élite sociale.
Le père de BHL, entrepreneur à succès,
est autodidacte
— c’est pas la même chose que d’être
fils de prof d’université, par exemple.
C’est donc à Normal Sup que BHL constitue
son capital culturel.
Il se rapproche des deux poids lourds intellectuels
de l’époque qui officient à l’école.
D’abord Jacques Derrida, le penseur emblématique
de la déconstruction.
Et puis encore plus de Louis Althusser, qui
est à l’époque la star intellectuelle
du marxisme grâce à ses livres Pour Marx
et Lire le Capital.
Comme tous les normaliens, BHL est fasciné
par l’aura intellectuelle d’Althusser.
Et donc comme beaucoup de ses camarades, il
adhère aux idées de Marx à la manière
d’Althusser.
Nous sommes en 1971-1972.
C’est la fin de la scolarité de BHL à
l’École normale supérieure.
Le secrétariat de François Mitterrand appelle
l’école.
Il cherche à joindre le responsable de la
section socialiste de l’école, un certain
« Bernard Lévy ».
Il ne s’agit pas de BHL, mais de son homonyme.
L’école informe BHL qu’il a rendez-vous
avec François Mitterrand le lendemain à
17h.
Que fait BHL ?
Il sait bien que ce n’est pas lui que Mitterrand
veut voir
— mais il prend quand même la place du
Bernard Lévy qui travaille depuis des années
dans l’ombre pour une telle occasion.
Et il ajoutera « Henri » à son prénom
afin que la confusion ne soit plus possible.
C’est une histoire vraie.
La rencontre se passe mieux que bien :
Mitterrand, séduit par l’assurance du jeune
BHL, décide de l’intégrer au groupe d’experts
qu’il constitue en vue de la prochaine présidentielle.
Une thématique précise revient à chaque
« expert ».
Je dis expert entre guillemets parce que BHL
ne connaît rien à sa thématique à lui,
l’autogestion,
c’est-à-dire le fait que les travailleurs
dirigent eux-mêmes leur entreprise, sans
patron.
Que fait-il : est-ce qu’il demande une autre
thématique ? Est-ce qu’il abandonne ?
Non, il propose… un livre sur le sujet à
Grasset, l’un des principaux éditeurs français
!
Il se dit que quitte à devenir rapidement
un expert sur le sujet, autant qu’il en
tire un bouquin.
Grasset refuse le projet, mais… embauche
BHL.
Il devient donc éditeur, à même pas 25
ans.
Pourquoi ce recrutement ?
Parce que BHL correspond parfaitement à l’évolution
du business model des maisons d’édition
à la fin des Trente Glorieuses.
Pour le dire très simplement, elles veulent
faire des « coups », c’est-à-dire s’assurer
de gros volumes de ventes en excitant l’opinion
publique.
Bien sûr, la clé d’un tel modèle, ce
sont le marketing et les médias.
BHL, un beau et brillant jeune normalien qui
sait se vendre comme personne et qui a déjà
un réseau dans l’élite culturelle
— un tel profil est parfait.
Et quel intérêt pour BHL de devenir éditeur
?
Pour le pouvoir culturel.
C’est l’éditeur qui décide de porter
à la publicité certaines idées.
Mais aussi pour le pouvoir social.
Être publié chez Grasset, c’est très
prestigieux.
Donc BHL acquiert le pouvoir de donner du
prestige social à quelqu’un
— ou de s’opposer à ce qu’il en acquiert.
Bien sûr, BHL ne décide pas seul et il est
jeune — mais son aide et son influence peuvent
être précieuses.
Ça permet d’être craint par tous ceux
qui ambitionnent d’être publiés : auteurs,
journalistes, hommes politiques, etc.
Enfin, c’est aussi le moyen le plus facile…
d’être soi-même publié.
À ma connaissance, la grande majorité, sinon
l’intégralité des livres de BHL sont sortis
chez Grasset.
En 1977, BHL a seulement 29 ans.
Il est invité à Apostrophes, l’émission
littéraire culte de France 2, pour la parution
de son premier essai, La Barbarie à visage
humain.
Son allure marque les téléspectateurs.
À l’aise dans une chemise blanche déboutonnée
à mi-poitrine, il tient une cigarette qui
reste le plus souvent en l’air
— comme sur les portraits de Malraux, son
modèle.
Son visage est encadré par une abondante
chevelure de play-boy romantique.
Le lendemain de l’émission, la fille du
présentateur, Bernard Pivot, lui dit : « Hier,
j’ai vu Rimbaud à la télé ».
Cette émission de 1977 marque l’éclosion
médiatique du mouvement philosophique dont
BHL est le représentant le plus charismatique,
les « Nouveaux Philosophes ».
Dans cette émission, il est accompagné par
l’autre figure emblématique du mouvement,
André Glucksmann, le père du journaliste
et homme politique Raphaël Glucksmann.
C’est BHL qui a baptisé le mouvement un
an plus tôt.
En tant qu’éditeur chez Grasset, il a publié
un groupe d’auteurs qu’il englobe dans
une même revendication théorique :
le naufrage de l’humanisme en philosophie
— c’est-à-dire la fin de la foi en la
capacité de la raison à améliorer la condition
humaine
— le naufrage de l’humanisme en philosophie,
cela ne signifie pas le naufrage de la philosophie.
Il faut donc être un NOUVEAU type de philosophe.
Mais la cohérence idéologique du mouvement
paraît tout de même fragile.
Les Nouveaux Philosophes se rassemblent grosso
modo autour de deux idées : le rejet du marxisme
et la condamnation des utopies.
Les critiques estiment qu’ils se définissent
davantage par leur méthode.
Ils sont de jeunes intellectuels médiatiques
particulièrement habiles à se mettre en
scène.
Leur émergence est notamment liée à la
démocratisation de la télévision dans la
société française depuis les années 1960.
Ils font ​​le choix de la légitimité
médiatique contre la crédibilité scientifique.
Cela fonctionne — et pas seulement en France.
Consécration immédiate, ils font la une
de l’hebdomadaire américain Time :
« Marx is dead, France’s new philosophers
speak out ».
Les plus grands médias occidentaux leur consacrent
des dossiers ou des documentaires.
Ils sont même invités à donner une série
de conférences au Mexique.
Au milieu de l’année 2010, beaucoup de
journaux — et pas seulement en France — évoquent
la même nouvelle : BHL et Arielle Dombasle
se seraient séparés.
Et on nous présente la nouvelle élue : l’héritière
des bières Guinness.
Pourquoi cette séparation intéresse-t-elle
tant les médias ?
Parce que BHL et Arielle Dombasle étaient
« The most famous couple in France », comme
l’écrivait le magazine américain Vanity
Fair en 2003.
Ce qui est intéressant dans cette anecdote,
ce n’est pas la vie privée de BHL.
C’est que son couple confirme sa stratégie
d’influence.
Pour occuper l’espace médiatique, il se
met en scène jusque dans sa vie romantique.
La plupart des gens qui le connaissent sont
incapables de citer un de ses livres ou un
de ses concepts
— mais ils suivent son couple avec Arielle
Dombasle.
D’ailleurs, elle bénéficie elle aussi
de la médiatisation de leur couple.
En fait, ils sont pareils :
la notoriété d’Arielle Dombasle est disproportionnée
par rapport à sa carrière d’actrice et
de chanteuse,
tout comme la notoriété de BHL est disproportionnée
par rapport à ses contributions philosophiques.
Pour le dire très simplement, les médias
ne les valorisent pas pour leur travail.
BHL est omniprésent dans les médias pour
la simple et bonne raison qu’il fait très
bien ce dont les médias ont besoin, leur
raison d’être : capter l’attention.
Arielle Dombasle, une belle blonde excentrique,
est parfaite à cet égard.
Pardon pour l’interruption, mais j’ai
une question à vous poser :
Vous croyez VRAIMENT que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on ne pourrait
pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale, ce
n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait, il n’y a pas qu’un seul
secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes les plus cultivés,
les profs, et les intellectuels CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets, mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT leur
culture générale, parce que leur rapport
au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur sur
n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour faire
preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes, donc
faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit ce que je voulais
vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
Vous vous souvenez peut-être du fameux débat
entre Nicolas Sarkozy, alors ministre de l’Intérieur,
et l’intellectuel musulman Tariq Ramadan.
C’était en 2003.
C’est pas simple pour le ministre de l’Intérieur
parce que son adversaire est un débatteur
hors pair.
Mais Nicolas Sarkozy s’en sort bien.
Comment s’est-il préparé ?
« Je l’ai fourni en munitions », dit BHL.
Ce serait donc son coaching intellectuel qui
aurait fait la différence.
La prestation du ministre de l’Intérieur
renforce son image de garant de l’autorité
de l’État face à l’intégrisme islamique.
C’est parfait en vue de la campagne présidentielle
de 2007.
BHL sera effectivement conseiller lors de
cette campagne.
Mais… de Ségolène Royal.
Et il ne se contente pas de la soutenir publiquement
dans les médias.
La candidate socialiste sollicite régulièrement
son avis.
Ils s’appellent même plusieurs fois par
jour à certaines périodes.
Pourtant, la relation de BHL avec Nicolas
Sarkozy ne se résume pas au coaching pour
le débat contre Tariq Ramadan.
En réalité, ils sont amis depuis plus de
20 ans !
Ils sont même partis en vacances ensemble
avec leurs familles respectives !
Cette anecdote montre que BHL n’est pas
sectaire.
Il dit que sa famille politique, c’est la
gauche — et effectivement, il a un gros
réseau parmi la gauche mitterandienne.
Mais il a de bons amis à droite : par exemple
Édouard Balladur, Dominique de Villepin,
ou encore Bruno Le Maire.
Et il ne s’implique pas uniquement à gauche.
En 2011, il joue par exemple un rôle clé
pour convaincre le gouvernement français
d’intervenir militairement contre Kadhafi
en Libye.
Ses détracteurs l’accusent de vouloir influencer
le pouvoir, peu importe la famille politique.
Lui explique qu’il s’implique pour une
cause, pas pour un camp.
En 2004, BHL accepte une proposition du magazine
américain The Atlantic Monthly :
écrire, 170 ans plus tard, une version moderne
de De la démocratie en Amérique de Tocqueville,
le grand classique de la philosophie politique
sur la démocratie américaine.
Pour cela, BHL doit faire un long voyage en
Amérique sur les traces de son compatriote.
Le but des chroniques que publiera The Atlantic
Monthly est de donner à l’Amérique un
nouveau diagnostic extérieur sur l’état
de sa démocratie.
American Vertigo, le livre qui compile les
chroniques, est un best-seller aux États-Unis.
Cette anecdote révèle que la notoriété
de BHL n’est pas franco-française.
Il y a deux raisons pour lesquelles The Atlantic
Monthly pense à lui pour le projet.
Tout d’abord, il incarne l’intellectuel
parisien tel qu’on l’imagine : brillant,
prétentieux, métaphysicien, charmeur, et
chic.
Mais en même temps, son personnage est suffisamment
mondialisé pour ne pas déstabiliser le public
américain.
La seconde raison pour laquelle The Atlantic
Monthly pense à lui, c’est qu’il est
ANTI-antiaméricain.
En effet, BHL dénonce la partie de la gauche
française qui critique les États-Unis par
principe, qui diabolise l’Amérique.
Il fera donc probablement un portrait sympathique
de l’Oncle Sam.
Le projet est un succès commercial et médiatique.
American Vertigo apparaît dans les listes
de best-sellers du New York Times et du Los
Angeles Times.
La tournée de promotion de BHL à travers
les États-Unis est triomphale.
Il passe tellement à la télévision que
les Américains le reconnaissent dans la rue.
Ce succès américain renforce son prestige
en France.
Mais sur le plan purement intellectuel, il
ne reste pas grand chose — contrairement
au voyage de Tocqueville.
Le propos du livre est superficiel, estiment
les critiques.
Et puis par rapport à son illustre prédécesseur,
BHL s’est contenté de rencontrer des stars
comme Sharon Stone, déconnectées de la réalité
de l’Américain ordinaire.
En 2010, BHL sort un nouveau livre de philo
: De la guerre en philosophie.
Et on peut lire à la page 122 :
« Ou bien encore Kant, le prétendu sage
de Königsberg, le philosophe sans vie et
sans corps par excellence, dont Jean-Baptiste
Botul a montré, au lendemain de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale, dans sa série de conférences
aux néokantiens du Paraguay, que leur héros
était un faux abstrait, et un pur esprit
de pure apparence. »
Si vous avez vu ma vidéo sur Kant, vous voyez
déjà un premier problème.
Kant n’est PAS DU TOUT « le philosophe
sans vie et sans corps par excellence » — c’est
même plutôt le contraire !
Donc BHL ne connaît pas la vie de Kant.
Et ensuite, si on est un peu curieux, on peut
se demander :
c’est qui ce « Jean-Baptiste Botul » qui
a donné une série de conférences au Paraguay
?
Un personnage de fiction.
Un philosophe fictif créé pour un canular
par un journaliste du Canard Enchaîné, Frédéric
Pagès.
L’article qui révèle l’erreur de BHL
devient viral.
Non seulement en France, mais aussi aux États-Unis.
« L’affaire Botul », comme on l’appelle,
révèle le manque de sérieux de BHL.
Ses adversaires se servent de l’affaire
pour le faire passer pour un imposteur.
Mais dire qu’il est un imposteur en philosophie,
c’est excessif.
Il est quand même diplômé de l’École
normale supérieure et agrégé de philosophie
— il a même fini 8ème au concours de l’agrégation.
Donc il a une formation TRÈS SOLIDE en philosophie.
Par ailleurs, personne ne l’a jamais traité
d’« imbécile ».
Au contraire, tous les témoignages — y
compris ceux de ses détracteurs — conduisent
à penser qu’il est très intelligent.
Donc le problème est ailleurs.
Le problème, c’est que créer une œuvre
digne de ce nom, ça demande de se consacrer
entièrement à un travail patient et minutieux.
BHL, lui, est un touche-à-tout pressé.
Kant, que BHL prétend discréditer en se
servant d’un philosophe fictif
— Kant a attendu la fin de la cinquantaine
pour être reconnu comme un penseur qui compte.
Après les attentats du 11 septembre 2001,
tous les regards se portent sur l’Afghanistan.
Le commandant Massoud, un opposant des talibans
assassiné deux jours avant l’attentat,
devient un symbole de la résistance au fondamentalisme
islamiste.
Dans un rapport remis aux autorités françaises
en 2002, BHL écrit :
« Je me souviens du commandant Massoud lors
de notre première rencontre, il y a vingt
ans ».
C’était lors de la guerre d’occupation
soviétique.
BHL s’était rendu sur place afin de livrer
des postes de radio à la résistance afghane.
Enfin… ça c’est sa version.
D’après une proche du commandant Massoud,
une médecin française qui forme des agents
de santé pour la résistance afghane, la
rencontre n’aurait pas eu lieu.
BHL n’aurait même pas franchi la frontière
de l’Afghanistan.
Je ne connais pas la vérité — mais ce
que montre cette anecdote, c’est que BHL
se met également en scène dans ses engagements
à l’international.
En fait, il se donne le rôle de l’intellectuel
engagé.
Mais il le fait avec un modèle bien précis
: André Malraux.
Malraux, c’est l’aventurier-romancier
devenu ministre de la Culture du général
De Gaulle.
Contrairement à Sartre, par exemple, Malraux
ne s’était pas contenté de prendre la
parole pour s’engager — lui se rendait
sur place.
Il a notamment combattu avec les républicains
contre les forces de Franco à la fin des
années 30 en Espagne ;
puis il a eu un rôle actif dans la Résistance
française (d’où sa proximité avec le
général de Gaulle).
BHL imite Malraux jusque dans la posture.
Comme lui, il brandit sa cigarette sans la
fumer.
Il tente de faire trembler sa voix dans ses
interventions publiques, comme Malraux lors
de son célèbre hommage à Jean Moulin.
Certes, BHL se rend bien sur place.
Au Pakistan, en Afghanistan, en Bosnie, au
Bangladesh, en Lybie, en Ukraine, etc.
Mais d’après les journalistes qui le côtoient
sur les théâtres d’opération, ce que
cherche BHL, c’est toujours à se mettre
en scène.
Il veut des preuves audiovisuelles de sa présence
et de son action.
Quitte à enjoliver les faits.
Quitte à les inventer, prétendent certains.
Mais Malraux ne le faisait-il pas ?
Peut-être que BHL, comme son modèle Malraux,
écrit le roman de sa vie.
Milieu 2010, Le Nouvel Observateur publie
un article intitulé « Et Onfray détrôna
BHL ».
Cela signifie que Bernard-Henri Lévy n’est
plus l’intellectuel le plus médiatique
de France.
Tout d’abord, ses livres ne se vendent plus.
BHL a pourtant donné beaucoup de best-sellers
pendant trente ans.
Plusieurs de ses titres ont atteint, voire
dépassé les 100 000 exemplaires.
Au total, grosso modo jusqu’aux années
2000, BHL a vendu plus d’un million de livres
— ce qui est énorme.
Mais à partir de 2010, c’est la chute.
Il ne dépasse plus les quelques milliers
de ventes.
Par exemple, De la guerre en philosophie (le
livre de l’affaire Botul) ne se vend qu’à
à peine plus de 4 000 exemplaires.
Les libraires constatent que la production
de BHL se vend exclusivement dans les quelques
semaines qui suivent la parution.
Les gens qui lisent de la philosophie n’achètent
plus les livres de BHL.
Michel Onfray, lui, enchaîne les best-sellers.
Et à des niveaux supérieux aux best-sellers
de BHL
(le Traité d’athéologie d’Onfray, bien
qu’il n’ait pas le titre le plus sexy
qui soit, a par exemple dépassé les 300
000 ventes).
Et Michel Onfray inspire davantage confiance
:
c’est un gros travailleur ; il ne commet
pas de grosses erreurs ;
il vient d’un milieu modeste, et il ne paraît
pas déconnecté de la réalité des Français.
En comparaison, BHL apparaît comme le défenseur
d’une oligarchie fanée.
Si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre. Ce travail est vraiment formidable
et passionnant. »
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable. J'étais
un peu dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas, c'est un vrai travail
de synthèse que tu nous proposes et le format
vidéo est très adapté pour moi qui ai une
mémoire essentiellement auditive. Le choix
des thèmes et des chapitres est pertinent
et je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite ; à la fois précis mais sans fioritures
! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme. Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultats : une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme,
je vous rembourserai intégralement si vous
estimez que vous n’avez pas acquis une solide
culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
Dans tous les cas, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu.
Je suis Romain, et vous, vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.